because it's christmas time
and the ground is white
let's gather round and sing a song
by the fire well is he cute i don't know
i don't know i mean he's just here for
the reindeer so
he is cute
diana you cannot just wallow in this
divorce you have to get back out there
i so don't want to get back out there
okay well if you don't want to do it for
yourself then do it for jake
for jake yes as soon as you move on with
your life he's going to move on with his
life too
he's job hunting sweetie he's
floundering
you cannot let him just do whatever he
wants you're enabling him
[Music]
what
[Music]
i just feel like you're always pushing
me
well that's our thing
[Music]
maybe this year i'm a little more
sensitive
okay but if i don't push you who will
besides bob's already remarried you
can't just let him win
[Music]
it's not always about winning
what is that supposed to mean
[Music]
i don't know like cheating on family
game night and then making your daughter
lie about it
she told you that
did you really cheat at charades
you were cheating mrs rivera
hi girls
look at those great outfits got any
cookies door deliveries are over wasn't
repeat really fake
no maddie your parents lost fair and
square okay it's madeline now
oh well sign me up for five boxes of
thin mints okay
sorry you'll have to wait until cookie
season like everyone else
[Music]
that trip was a propaganda machine they
destroyed briefland again well bree
flanagan was arrested for shoplifting
and who turned her in troop nine
how could you do that to me i didn't see
them you didn't see five girl scouts
popping out of christmas trees no i go
tell them you're joking
no
that's what you always want me to do i
always defend you
what is wrong with you today well
apparently everything my husband left me
i'm not ready to move on i'm a bad
parent i never said you were a bad
parent okay i'm being a friend and
friends tell each other things that they
don't always want to hear okay well in
the spirit of friendship you should know
that skye thinks that you smother her
mother i mean my god trish let her live
her life for five minutes without you
planning everything about it oh really
well you want to know why jake's really
back home because you want him there so
you don't have to be alone
when the kids were freshmen and you were
in turks and caicos
this guy asked me to adopt her
why would my daughter want to trade down
i don't know
but
maybe i did see those girl scouts
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
you want to see a show everybody
trish's signature pumpkin cheesecake
recipe
is bobby flays
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god did you hear about trish
rivera she got caught cheating at
christmas charades who does that
are you kidding me look trish tells
everyone she's 44. honey i know for a
fat she is 49.
now this is what i'm talking about you
can just see the hostility in diana's
paintings look at those antlers you know
trish and diana's houses are right
across the street from each other which
means one of them might be on the market
soon i hope it's trish
bigger commish
so what did she throw
i didn't serve it but my sources tell me
it was an iced holiday latte with double
whipped cream messy
uh did something happen trish and banana
split up officially not like that fake
fight they had no nine that's awful
seriously what will we do for
entertainment now
[Music]
[Music]
you